for more on tonight's vice presidential
debate we're joined by cbs news
political contributors jamal simmons
and terry sullivan uh gentlemen good
morning to both you jamal i want to go
to you first
the democrats would seem to have a
slight edge according to the polls going
into tonight
so what does senator harris have to do
to move people to the polls and actually
get this vote out
hey tony thanks for having me and my
commute this morning was very short i'm
here at home
so this is a good this is a good
show to do today so i think that conley
harris has to
uh you know she's gotten a lot of
excitement for things like her
chuck taylor's that she's been wearing
and the boots the timberland boots she's
been wearing but tonight's an
opportunity for her to put some more
meat on the bone about our policy chops
and what we know
is uh you know senator harris has done
very well in debates during the
presidential primaries
one of the things that may have gotten
in her way when she was trying to be
vice president
was the way she took on joe biden so we
know she can deliver a punch
what we have to see also tonight though
is can she counter punch
when she's been hit because that
sometimes has not been
her best strength so we'll see tonight
whether or not she can deliver a punch
she can counter punch and she'll focus i
think from talking to the campaign
they'll be focused more on president
trump than they are on vice president
pence who's a nice guy but is a tough
debater
all right terry same question to you
penn says you say pence is a nice guy he
once described himself
as rush limbaugh on decaf he used to be
a talk radio host before he got into
politics
terry similar question to you what do
you expect from vice president pence
and how important will tonight's debate
be for the republican ticket
yeah look i mean i spent 20 years as a
campaign manager from everything from
the state house to the white house
preparing candidates and debate prep
and and there's two real things that you
have to focus on as preparing a
candidate
which number one is prepared for any
question so that you can answer it
answer it and then turn around and pivot
and go back and deliver your message
and the message of of donald trump
and mike pence is that they are the best
to lead
the country economically out of this
crisis
and so you saw the president last night
was able to turn this back around and
make it an economic issue it seems like
it was a crazy way to do it but he was
able to do it
and that is their message and that's
what you're going to expect vice
president pence doing tonight he's going
to
he's going to pilot her attacks i mean
she's a former prosecutor she's going to
be good
you saw what she did to joe biden during
the debates and how she attacked him
ruthlessly and implying that he was a
racist
you know terry's gonna have to turn back
terry we were just looking at some
numbers this morning showing uh
that the trump pence ticket is trailing
among seniors people over the age of 65
by double digits i mean in fact in the
20s and this is a group that
the president won in 2016. a lot of that
has got to do with the virus response do
you expect a different tone
from vice president pence the head of
the coronavirus task force this evening
sure i mean look i think you can expect
the same tone that you have from vice
president
pence all the time but that is a very
different tone than the president's tone
um so i think you're going to expect
more of the same from him from as far as
a tone
but that's always been a very different
tone than the uh than the president's
tone so
you know it will change but but he's
going to be consistent
jamal i know that you have coached
candidates in the past when debating a
woman
i didn't even know that was a thing so
what is the difference on how
on how debate prep is handled when
you're working with a female candidate
question for you both jamal yeah i think
every
yeah everybody has gail everybody has a
couple of different things to worry
about i mean barack obama had to be
worried about being an angry black man
when he was
you know out there doing some of the
debate uh those debates kamala harris
has to be worried about being a black
woman in a very similar
a very similar context um but for mike
pence i think he's got to be worried
about whether or not
he seems too aggressive when he's coming
at kamala harris i mean he can
he can obviously he's got to go at her
record he's got to talk about her and
whether or not
absolutely absolutely but you always
have to calibrate how people are getting
this at home and so you got to pay a
little bit of attention to that
but then we have donald trump on the
other hand who threw all the rules out
the window i mean he
stalked hillary clinton as they walked
around that debate stage four years ago
i mean he but nobody can do what donald
trump can do
uh he's a candidate of his own the
question for for kamala harris is going
to be can she go after donald trump's
record
even though that he's you know obviously
sick but he says he's back in the game
so i think he's fair game for tonight um
with and knowing that mike pence is
going to be a fierce
sometimes monotone but a fierce defender
of their record
even though this trump white house shows
that it can't be trusted
to do the right thing when it comes to
the virus we're all at home right now
because they haven't figured out how to
solve this problem all right terry you
want to wrap it up in 30 seconds
yeah i i think that that we're not all
at home because they haven't figured out
how to solve this problem
i think those are the kind of the over
the top like look we've got a national
crisis
we're trying to get through this there's
plenty of blame to go around but but
it's it's with the coronavirus
not a politician all right terry
sullivan
jamal simmons always good to see you